[Music]
it feels so good the ladies of 3lw are
together again
well kind of more like 2lw
[Music]
adrian houghton shared this pic
reuniting with natori naughton one of
her former band bates of the early 2000s
girl group 3lw
[Music]
that's adrian in a black denim number
and natori rocking a red matching set
the fitting caption for the occasion
2lw
let the healing begin
[Music]
so what healing is taking place well we
gotta go back to the beginning to fully
understand
in 1999 3lw was formed with adrian
natori and their other bandmate keeley
williams the girls had a string of hits
including this one we couldn't get out
of our heads
[Music]
i remember
gluing rhinestones to my belly button
because i wasn't allowed to get my belly
button pierced but that was all the rage
at the time with britney spears and
christina aguilera doing it i remember
going on tour with destiny's child the
trl tour which was epic and it was a
great time in music
but fans of the group know drama erupted
between the trio
including an alleged incident involving
food which natori addressed in 2019. for
the record a lot of people ask me did
y'all really have a fight at kfc
yes we did i said i'm not the one who's
trying to kick me out the group there
were some names called some profanities
thrown
she turned around kelly and threw the
plate of food mashed potatoes chicken
whatever else was in there in my face
and i got out the car and i was just
like i'm going home they drove off with
that driver and left me in the parking
lot in atlanta georgia fast forward to
2017 and adrian publicly apologized to
natori on her daytime talk show the real
there was a lot that went on in that
time that now looking back is just like
it was so young and it was crazy yeah
that i genuinely from the bottom of my
heart never meant any harm towards you
and that i think you're talented and
beautiful thank you
but where does keeley stand in all of
this
well last year she opened up to et about
the beef and if she has a relationship
with the ladies today
it's nothing new i did not throw a
bucket of chicken at her can i ask where
your relationship with nature stands
today were you guys able to make peace
or or make amends at some point no i do
not speak to natori where do you and
adrian stand today i also do not speak
to adrian um
no
all of the the nature adrian thing is
kind of all like kind of mixed up in
together um and not to say that i would
lump them in as
the same person i think it's unfortunate
that after all of these years and all
the success that they've been able to
achieve that they wouldn't use their
platforms to be more honest about really
what happened with the group um
but that's life you know and if you're
wishing for a 3lw comeback well this new
reunion photo gives us hope but we're
not holding our breath i feel like we've
all gone in so many different directions
i feel like 3lw is like sacred and we'll
keep it there and keely she says she's
more likely to do a cheetah girls
project the girl group she and adrian
joined after 3lw split alongside raven
simone and sabrina bryan i definitely
think the cheetah girls is is probably
the the avenue that it would be just
because
regardless of like past history everyone
is so professional i mean there is a
healthy amount of ego there but i really
think that we all approach the cheetah
girls from a really professional
standpoint so i i think
that
that is more likely
in the meantime we'll enjoy this 2lw
reunion
[Music]